♪♪
-♪ It was late last night
in the spooky fog ♪
♪ It was the rager of the year
in a haunted bog ♪
♪ The monsters all mashed
with evil laughter ♪
♪ Everyone had fun ♪
♪ Until the morning after ♪
-♪ Hangover mash ♪
-♪ It's the hangover mash ♪
-♪ Last night,
they were way too smashed ♪
-♪ Hangover mash ♪
-♪ They got obliterated ♪
-♪ Now, they're just
nauseated ♪
-♪ Frankenstein did 13
jagerbombs last night ♪
♪ This morning,
he's cradling a Pedialyte ♪
♪ Dracula puked in his laundry
basket by his bed ♪
♪ Wishing, for once,
that he could just be dead ♪
-♪ Monsters feel bad ♪
-♪ The party was
a slaughter ♪
-♪ Monsters feel bad ♪
-♪ Now, they can't
keep down water ♪
-♪ Monsters feel bad ♪
-♪ They're crying
on the toilet ♪
-♪ Monsters feel bad ♪
-♪ Check the bed,
did they soil it? ♪
-♪ The mummy had unraveled
all over the room ♪
♪ Tried to pull himself together
for his 9:00 a.m. Zoom ♪
♪ To try to ease his nausea
through this ghastly slog ♪
♪ The wolfman cracked
a White Claw ♪
♪ The hair of the dog ♪
-♪ Dracula hissed
at the sight of dawn ♪
♪ Swamp Thing
lost the remote ♪
♪ So he watched
whatever was on ♪
♪ Frankenstein told his bride
form evil deeds he'd repent ♪
♪ But she would only delete
all the nudes that he sent ♪
-♪ They got so smashed ♪
-♪ They're all
full of regret ♪
-♪ They got so smashed ♪
-♪ And smell like
old cigarettes ♪
-♪ They got so smashed ♪
-♪ They just got tagged
on Instagram ♪
-♪ They got so smashed ♪
-♪ Barfing mid-keg stand ♪
♪ This is the last time
those monsters go drinking ♪
♪ Whatever could have
those ghouls been thinking? ♪
♪ Never again will
those creatures imbibe ♪
♪ Well, maybe just
a bit tonight ♪
-♪ Hangover mash ♪
-♪ Their night
was a thriller ♪
-♪ Hangover mash ♪
-♪ Now, they're downing
pain killers ♪
-♪ Hangover mash ♪
-♪ They're now just
barfing a little ♪
-♪ Hangover mash ♪
-♪ Should someone
call the hospital? ♪
[ Groaning ]
♪♪